So, you want to write some po
choreography, but all you know are
beginner tricks. Does that mean it's a
hopeless cause that you got to wait
until you get further down that trick
tree? No. No, it does not. As it turns
out, you can write a great piece of po
choreography even with the most basic of
beginner tricks. It all just depends how
exactly you structure that choreography.
And I am going to give you the secrets
to doing so in this video.
Drex here from Drex Factor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video I'm going to
show you how you can choreograph an
amazing combo even with the most basic
of PO tricks. But before we dive in, I
just want to give a quick shout out to
the friends of the channel. Big thanks
go to Dark Monk, Fire Mecca, Flowfests,
Flow Toys, Pyroer Light Toys, and
Ultraoy for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible. You can learn
more about all these amazing companies
and the work that they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video. And just to
put a massive thank you out there to
Pekka Beckon for having supported this
channel for so very long. I appreciate
you and everything that you've done
these past few years. All right, so
first a little bit of groundwork. See, I
think we in the PO world sometimes get
just a little bit too obsessed with our
tricks and specifically the difficulty
level of them. Absolutely. More
difficult tricks can get you a lot of
respect when you show them off. But that
doesn't mean that they are the only
option when it comes to writing
choreography. And whether working with
beginner, intermediate, advanced, or pie
in the sky tricks, the same principles
apply for putting together a really
satisfying piece of choreography. So to
give you an example of this in action,
I'm going to share with you one of my
favorite pieces of choreography that I
have ever written. I came up with it a
few months ago and it centers entirely
about building up to one po trick, the
windmill. So first and foremost, here's
the choreography itself and then I'll
explain why it works.
[Music]
So regardless of the skill level of the
tricks, that you're working with. What
really matters is the structure, the
choreography that you build around them.
And one of the devices that I use in
this piece of choreography is something
called the rule of threes, which I
guarantee you you're familiar with, even
if you don't recognize the name. The
rule of threes is actually operating in
most jokes you've ever heard. So, for
example, a priest walks into a bar,
takes a shot from the bartender, sits
down, and prays for him. Then, a monk
walks in, takes a shot from the
bartender, sits down, and prays for him.
Then a rabbit walks into the bar, says
to the bartender, "I'm pretty sure that
I'm a typo." See how I've created a
setup with two examples that are very
similar, and then I twist the concept on
its head with the last one. That is the
rule of threes in action. This is an
effective storytelling device because it
plays with the audience's expectations,
and it introduces some level of novelty
into the structure. It's excellent for
keeping people's attention. So, by my
account, I use the rule of threes three
separate times in the course of this
combo. So, let's examine exactly how it
works and how I use it. We start off by
doing these little loops over my
shoulders, going to stage right and
stage left, stalling the PO each time. I
have created a theme and I'm going to
tweak it just slightly on this next
repetition. As I go over to stage right,
rather than stalling both po, I keep the
one on my left hand spinning. It's not
much of a change, but it's enough
novelty to keep the audience engaged.
From here, I do a big extension with my
left hand, bring it back, and then do a
little loop over my left shoulder. Now,
the extension and the loop are slightly
different, but the overall theme is that
my right hand is staying still and my
left hand is exploring both little
circles as well as big circles. So, that
on the final repetition, when I get the
right hand engaged and going up into a
windmill, it reads as a massive spike in
novelty. and more than that, what the
combo was building to the entire time.
Finally, I do one, two reps of a big
windmill, one, two of a small windmill,
and then switch to the archer fountain.
We already know that the windmill was
what I was working up to, so I show two
different variations on it, and then
finish out with one little added bit of
spice in order to bring the audience in
for a landing. Awesome. And you may have
noticed that I use the end of one
section of a rule of three as the
beginning of another section of a rule
of three. So I can gradually build the
audience's anticipation and add just a
little bit more interest every step of
the way. But that's not the only thing
going on under the hood here. Another
helpful tool we have for arranging our
po choreography is using changes in
pacing to both build anticipation as
well as release energy as well. So let
me unpack something about our example
combo that may not be obvious at first.
Namely, as I'm going across the first
section from stage left to stage right,
I take a full 4 count to get there and
another four count to change focus at
the audience and then come back. When I
go back to stage left, I take the 4
count to go and then immediately come
back. In other words, the second section
takes half as long as the first one. And
then when I switch to the final one, I
don't even complete the full set of
stalls. In other words, I've compressed
the timeline to rush the audience
towards a conclusion. And in the section
with the extensions, I do exactly the
opposite. Namely, I do my extension,
pause, I do my loop and pause, and
there's an extended part in the music
here where things get stretched out a
little before finally arriving in the
windmill. It builds more anticipation
because I'm stretching out the timeline
in order to get there. And then finally,
when we do get into the windmills, going
big twice, I then go small on the ladder
set. This speeds the windmills up and
again it adds a little bit of urgency.
So by both compressing as well as
stretching out different parts of the
choreography, I can both build the
audience's anticipation for the next
part as well as leave them in suspense
so that when we finally get to the
payoff, oh my goodness, does it feel
good to get there. The final structural
device that I want to take you all
through here is called foreshadowing.
And what it is is introducing elements
that are later going to pay off in the
thing at the climax that you are guiding
your audience to the whole time. Let me
show you how. So, our example combo is
all about just one thing, the windmill,
and getting the audience to the windmill
and making it feel like a big deal. So,
how exactly do we do this? Well, I
introduce several elements of the
windmill along the way so that when all
those elements come together, it feels
like a katharsis. First and foremost, as
I'm taking these loops over my
shoulders, it introduces the element of
shoulder reels. That is the PO going
back and forth in front of and behind
our shoulders, which of course is core
to windmills. Next, I play around with
both extensions as well as producing a
small loop over my shoulder with just
one hand at a time. This introduces the
element of volume as well as keeping the
movement of the PO continuous. Remember,
we start off doing stalls as we're going
back and forth here. So, introducing the
idea that the poi can just keep on
moving is adding another layer to it.
Finally, when we bring both of the poi
into it, all these elements coales
together. We see both of the poi
working. We see both of them performing
loops over my shoulders and eating up a
lot of volume in the process. And the
cherry on top is switching into the
small windmills, the classic
presentation of them to really bring the
whole thing home. See, in all of these
cases, what I'm doing is I'm introducing
incomplete aspects of the windmill and
introducing them in such a way that it
is clear that they are incomplete. And
in that way, when all the elements meld
together, it feels like a payoff for the
audience. So, I want you to take these
elements and have them inform your
choreography. If you use devices like
this to structure your choreography, it
will be satisfying regardless of the
skill level of the tricks involved. And
pretty please as you're exploring these
elements in your own choreography, do
make sure to post the results and tag
me. I am Drexfactor on all platforms and
I would love to see your wonderful work.
Please make sure to like, share,
comment, and subscribe to help other
people find this video as well as to
help my channel grow. Thanks.
This video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a shout out
to my Flo patrons who are listed on
screen right now. Thank you all so much.
You rock. And if you would like to get
your name in the credits or access to
any of a host of other rewards such as
being able to suggest videos to me such
as the one you just watched, this was
actually a Patreon requested video. Uh
you can head on over to my Patreon at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo
and sign up. The link is included down
in the description as well as up in the
cards. Go check that out, please. And
thank you. And if you would like to
learn more about choreographing
techniques such as blocking, I'll go
ahead and include a link to a video I've
done on that topic right here. Uh I'll
also include the link down in the
description. Thank you so much for
watching. Make sure to get out and flow
to yourselves today. And I'll see you
with a new video real soon. Take care
now. Peace.